et c'est donc le 21 février dernier que
votre chien Bayou va être volé quand
vous savez qu'il a été volé qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé je le sais tout de suite
parce que déjà quand je siffle il
revient très rapidement et surtout on
envoie un message sur le groupe d'une de
notre association
pour déjà une association en fait on a
monté une association pour obtenir le
square derrière que vous voyez le droit
de parce qu'il faut savoir qu'à Paris
aucun chien n'est accepté dans aucun
parc même en laisse donc plus rien
faire il est chiant
un truc restez chez vous il est privé
et donc là vous et donc on a obtenu ce
parc et voilà c'est un peu son spot
c'est d'ailleurs à proximité il y a un
escalier qui descend tout les marches du
funiculaire de Montmartre qui est juste
limitrophe à ce parc et
c'est là qu'il a a priori était volé
parce que ce soir là il avait une laisse
et
au moins moi j'avais mon chien
généralement sans laisse il était tout
le temps avec moi
voilà c'est c'était mon sang quoi et du
coup
du coup vol d'opportunité je pense ou
trafic je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est un croisé donc
qui a 6 ans je m'attendais absolument
pas à ce qu'on puisse envisager de me
voler un chien qui est pas d'une race ou
parce que c'est un vrai phénomène en
expansion à Paris à ce que vous fassiez
voler votre chien non c'est pour moi
enfin déjà je comprends pas qu'on puisse
voler des êtres vivants comme des
téléphones portables mais moi mon chien
c'était pas une race quoi c'était pas un
chien
catégorisé qui était qui était enfin qui
était qui valait de l'argent qui avait
une valeur pécuniaire je l'ai eu par une
association qui les récupère dans les
pays où ils sont maltraités donc
là
vous êtes dit mon chien non
non et puis en plus c'est un chien très
libre et donc du coup c'était pas un
tout petit chien non plus il fait
presque 60 cm au collège donc
je vois pas
6 ans 6 ans
alors ça vous a connu une énorme peine
je sais que c'était voilà vous étiez
c'est comme si c'était un membre de ma
famille comprenait quoi c'est ça ah oui
comme pour tout le monde tous ceux qui
ont des animaux
et donc dès le départ vous êtes dans
l'optique de tout faire pour le
récupérer vous allez aller au
commissariat pour faire une portée
plainte parce qu'on vous a volé votre
chien ou pas du tout ouais si je veux
porter plainte
je vais porter plainte mais du coup on
m'appelle si jour après pour me dire
qu'on ouvre le dossier
et qu'effectivement comme je l'ai dit
depuis le premier jour on voit bien mon
chien à 18h59 sur filmé par les caméras
du en bas du funiculaire de Montmartre
avec le voleur qui est en train de
partir
donc ça c'est une caméra c'est pas une
caméra publique c'est une caméra voyant
l'inertie de l'enquêteur qui qui
s'occupait de l'affaire le lendemain il
me dit qu'il va pas regarder toutes les
caméras de
Montmartre pour un chien donc je décide
avec ma compagne de d'aller voir moi si
à tout hasard il y a une boutique qui
filmerait pas sur la rue
vu que j'ai un créneau horaire assez
précis et même si c'est une aiguille
dans une botte de foin très vite
je vois une caméra qui donne sur une rue
au croisement avec le boulevard
Rochechouart
et je vais voir le vigile je lui donne
le créneau horaire et il me
identifie tout de suite le chien sur la
caméra avec le voleur alors mais que
vous a dit parce que c'est intéressant
pour noter les spectateurs qu'est-ce qui
vous ont dit les enquêteurs et vous ont
dit quoi en fait moi j'ai pas je suis
pas là pour cracher sur la peau déjà non
mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
la police doit aller rechercher un chien
ou bien c'est ce qu'on m'a dit on m'a
dit non aujourd'hui ils sont pas et ils
sont pas militaires les gens ils sont
pas responsables d'une procédure qui a
pas suivi une loi qui a eu lieu il y a
un an qui a arrêté de considérer les
animaux de compagnie ou les animaux tout
court d'ailleurs comme des biens meubles
c'est-à-dire que avant la loi disait que
c'était comme un objet comme un
aspirateur comme un téléphone
donc
en revanche ça c'est bien c'est c'est un
peu tardif mais il faut tard que jamais
le sauf que ça a pas du tout suivi sur
les procédures donc à la décharge de la
police déjà ils ont pas de protocole
autre que ils ont même pas le choix de
classer la plainte autrement que comme
un vol simple et donc du coup
ils ont pas la permission ou la fin de
lancer des avis de recherche sur le
moment quand ça se passe de visionner
les caméras en urgence alors on sait
très bien qu'on enlèvement c'est le
temps qui compte quoi on va voir les
images on voit très clairement le voleur
de de votre chien elles sont très
claires vous les avez donné aux
enquêteurs ces images finalement alors
en fait donc ce fameux policier qui m'a
sorti cette phrase qui je l'avoue à m'a
fait un peu sortir de mes goûts du coup
moi le
si on va pas regarder toutes les caméras
pour un chien
et je le comprends parce qu'il a pas
longtemps il y a plus d'argent pour
l'éducation il y a plus d'argent pour la
santé
comment sauf que là il a quand même pour
tous les vols il y a pas quand même
presque un flagrant délit parce que là
le quand il a filmé par lesquelles quand
il est filmé par les caméras publiques
ça fait moins d'une minute qu'il a le
chien quoi donc
toujours est-il que je sais plus c'était
quoi votre question est-ce que vous les
avez donné aux enquêteurs des images
donc clairement moi
vous voyez le gars vous savez qui c'est
identifiable le lendemain quand
j'entends cette phrase
je raccroche le téléphone
et je décide donc d'aller chercher cette
caméra et donc tout content
j'appelle le policier qui ne m'a jamais
répondu je l'ai fait appelé par ma
compagne parce que vu que moi
apparemment
ça le touchait pas je me suis dit
peut-être que
il a jamais répondu au téléphone donc le
lendemain je lui renvoie des textos et
avec la
photo de la caméra que vous avez montré
là pour qu'il voit bien quand même que
s'il a été filmé il a il va être
beaucoup plus identifiable que sur des
caméras publiques
et le mec me répond simplement que la
plainte a été classée voilà 48 heures 48
heures ou 48 heures c'est fini la
plainte est classée c'est classé donc là
le chien c'est fini et c'est classé pour
manque d'éléments soit disant sauf que
moi au bout de 24 heures je lui ai amené
ce nouvel élément bien permettre de
c'est incroyable même retracer tout son
trajet jusqu'à 62000 soit peut-être que
là il est au téléphone pendant tout le
vol donc peut-être qu'il est en train de
demander à un mec de venir le chercher
en voiture tout est possible en fait les
appels et donc là pour le chien Gilles
c'est c'est quoi c'est cuit bon alors ce
qu'il faut dire quand même souvent je
défends la police mais là ils ont mal
fait leur boulot quoi qu'il arrive alors
c'est vrai Cyril vous le disiez que
c'est pas considéré comme un enlèvement
donc du coup c'est simplement un vol
simple et là ce que ça prouve sur la
photo c'est pas le vol mais ça pourrait
être recel de vol puisqu'il y a pas le
moment où ils le vole mais ça pourrait
être du Russell de vol voilà mon chien
il le récupère absolument sans moi donc
absolument il le récupère sans
autorisation c'est pas son chien ça
c'est clair donc là la police aurait pu
avec ces vidéos tenter de retrouver la
vraie réponse Cyril ça a été évoqué
c'est que malheureusement les policiers
estiment avoir autre chose à faire que
de tenter de retrouver un chien de
manière très aléatoire c'est honteux je
pense pas du tout la défense et honteux
mais voilà la raison de quoi sur ils
estiment que de toute façon c'est peine
perdue ou que ils ont tous parce que si
j'ai pu reporter plein de vendredi bien
sûr grâce à une policière qui est archi
dévouée à la cause animale et qui
voilà c'est ce que c'est que de perdre
c'est même pas un animal de compagnie
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de la famille
quoi et pour tous ceux qui ont des
chiens c'est pareil quoi et ça le fait
que vous ayez montré les images et ces
images qu'on voit on voit le le voleur
présumé voleur
est-ce que ça rouvre pas le dossier non
bah non justement moi c'est ce que j'ai
cru en fait moi j'ai cru que parce que
j'ai réussi à faire un complément de
plainte mais moi je connais pas bien la
loi et je pensais que je pouvais pas
faire de complément de plainte sur une
plainte déjà classé en fait le policier
à qui je donne cette caméra alors
qu'elle est déjà classée normalement
d'après la procédure il a même pas le
droit de demander les autres caméras du
secteur puisqu'il est pas sur une
enquête il est pas chargé avec une
enquête de pouvoir requisitionner alors
un pote qui me dit le gars téléphone si
on a l'heure de la photo on peut le
retrouver
ouais c'est ça de moi j'y pense depuis
le début Roger les coups de fil
à ce moment là parce que là ça c'est à
19h02 j'avais essayé de retourner dans
le quartier pour voir si vous vous
retrouvez ce gars mais j'habite dans ce
quartier donc je le signal de je connais
vu ce gars
quand on peut dire que le policiers
n'ont pas que ça à faire il y a d'autres
trucs à traiter que les chiens les chats
les perruches les perroquets tous ces
animaux qui sont evanés mais là on a le
gars on a la photo on a le thé on sait
qu'il est au téléphone pourquoi pas
retracellent pour qu'on a on a sa tête
on peut l'identifier la question c'est
débile ma question c'était parti avec un
enfant on le retrouve pas non plus on a
sa tête on a tout si par avec un enfant
le retrouve ou pas et ben si par un
chien et qu'il est là ici
c'est griller tout seul on voit sa tête
si c'est un enfant on aurait peut-être
cherché le mec pourquoi on va pas le
chercher pour prendre son chien vous
avez essayé là c'est pas long
communication animale parce que si vous
montrez une photo à quelqu'un peut-être
communiquer avec le je suis hier j'ai
été en contact avec une dame de Gironde
là je dois être en contact avec une
autre personne
demain enfin oui j'ai des personnes moi
j'y crois vous leur montrez une photo de
votre chien elles peuvent communiquer
avec le chien et vous dire ce qui
ressent et où il se retrouve peut-être
où il se trouve
la communication animale j'avais une
copine et vous avez pas peur en venant
ici ce soir par exemple que la personne
se reconnaisse avec votre chien et
s'estime peut-être être traquée reconnu
et se disent oulala attention et du coup
voilà qu'il soit mal intentionné déjà il
est mal intentionné avec peut-être le
relâche
il peut tout à fait le donner à
quelqu'un à qui je vais donner une
récompense la remercier et enfin c'est
franchement moi je voilà je veux
retrouver mon chien en priorité et bien
sûr j'aimerais que ça puisse pas arriver
j'aimerais que les gens sont soit
beaucoup plus assistés quand ça leur
arrive surtout dans des cas comme ça où
il y a vraiment moyen de faire vraiment
une enquête une plainte elle est classée
71 ça veut dire manque d'éléments
manque d'éléments moi s'il m'avait
répondu au téléphone on est alors vous
avez 50 jours que Bayou vous a été volé
est-ce que vous avez encore espoir de le
retrouver vraiment oui si vous êtes là
ce soir c'est clair de toute façon je
lâcherai jamais c'est mon sang qu'on m'a
arraché donc
ouais des années
là je vais reprendre une chaîne pour que
qu'il ait
une femme quand il revient on sait qu'il
va revenir
ouais je vais retrouver de façon je vais
le retrouver je vais le retrouver à part
si store dur lui fait du mal et décide
de le tuer mais je sais pas j'avais peur
qu'il soit mal qui soit maltraités qui
soient morts
on passe partout les
de toute façon pour moi depuis un mois
et demi je suis archi soutenu par ma
femme qui m'aime mais surtout par mon
meilleur ami qui qui vient afficher avec
moi qui passe toute sa vie
pour pour le chercher avec moi et
ouais bien sûr que il y a des moments je
suis terrorisé il y a des moments je
suis rempli d'espoir là j'ai mon
téléphone qui sonne j'ai envie de
décrocher parce que j'ai
peur que ça soit quelqu'un qui me dise
qu'il est avec lui quoi
est-ce que si la personne vous ramène le
chien devant chez vous est-ce que vous
vous engagez pour retirer toutes ces
poursuites
non ouais non mais il a il a raccroché
tout de suite sur la troisième fois
est-ce que vous arrêtez toutes les
poursuites et ce que vous prenez votre
chien parce que ça se trouve le mec il a
peur de vous attends il y a peut-être
quelqu'un
oui allô
[Musique]
oui
moi je me suis trompé numéro
c'est le numéro qu'on avait à l'antenne
qui est passé à l'antenne là qui sonne
là
il va péter le numéro je pense
c'est bizarre que vous receviez un coup
de fil en direct à 21h09
bon voilà il va exploser je pense que
c'est quoi c'est votre numéro
pour le chat là
accroche
la tête on peut afficher l'adresse mail
en fait comme ça les gens oui allô je
vous écoute c'était pour vous dire que
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé les informations
qu'est-ce qui quoi
des
envoyez moi une photo parce que sinon
enfin
votre numéro il va exploser bah c'est
normal on l'a mis aussi pour qu'elle est
témoignages
je pense que ça peut bouger ça peut
bouger Nicolas
de toute façon j'imagine bien que si je
touche plusieurs millions de personnes
il va bien y avoir des haters
peut-être qu'il y aura une bonne
personne qui va vous envoyer
un message
merci de rien vous y croyez encore plus
maintenant
bah j'y crois enfin
de toute façon je fais ça pour euh enfin
voilà pour rapidement quoi
non mais arrête pas de tenir au revoir
et si vous pouvez nous donner des
nouvelles assez vite Nicolas et je pense
qu'en fait que ce qu'on a fait ce soir
peut-être ça va faire les choses et que
vous allez avoir des vrais témoignages
voilà je vous le dis si vous nous
regardez ceux qui sont là pour faire des
blagues et appeler pour dire des bêtises
ça sert à rien
c'est que il faut que mon téléphone soit
encore fonctionnel quoi parce que si
effectivement je suis harcelé de mecs
bah voilà de toute façon je posterai sur
un nouveau numéro puisque celui-là je
pense que ça va être mort pendant
quelques jours
[Rires]
et je suis persuadé que là on va on va
on va le retrouver en tout cas vous nous
tenez au courant on est avec vous à fond
et comme on dit il y aura peut-être une
chaîne de solidarité de tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent car
on sait ce que c'est que le numéro et
dire aux gens juste sms
il y a une bonne information